[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان في الوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه الان تقع واحداثهم
وتتفاعل اخرى لنبدا من العاصمه الايرانيه
طهران وعوده في الحديث عن الملف النووي
الى الواجهه في ضوء اتصالات ايرانيه
اوروبيه وتصريحات من واشنطن لا تبدي فيها
استعجالا به
ومن العاصمه الروسيه موسكو يصلون هذه
الصور في وقت تقول فيه السلطات المحليه في
جنوب غرب روسيا ان قصف اوكرانيا استهدف
مواقع في اقليمين روسيين
ومن لندن هذه الجوله مع التجدد اضراب
العاملين في قطاع التمريض مطالبين برفع
الاجور وتحسين ظروف العمل عدد المشاركين
في هذا الاضراب يقدر ب 100000
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
واشنطن تقول ان الاتفاق النووي مع ايران
ليس محلها اهتمامها في الوقت الراهن وتشكك
في فرص احراز تقدم فيه
العلاقه بين الاتحاد الاوروبي وايران
ويدعو في لقاء مع عبد الله الى ابقاء
قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه وطهران تعلن
استعدادها للوصول الى نتيجه الايجابيه
وتحث على الابتعاد عن تاسيس الملف
مع اقراري بوتر بصعوبه المرحله واهميتها
زنسكي يحل بمدينه محمود الاستراتيجيه
الشرقيه اوكرانيا بعد اعلان الانفصاليين
ومرتزقه فاجنر قرب سيطرتهم عليها
وروسيا تقول ان الجيش الاوكراني قصف مناطق
داخل اراضيها
اثر اعتقال رئيس الحكومه التونسيه السابق
علي العريض الامم المتحده تحث على احترام
حقوقه حركه النهضه تقول ان هدف الاعتقال
هو التغطيه على مسمته الفشل في الانتخابات
جبهه الخلاص كان في وجود مبررات قانونيه
ورئيس سعيد ينتقد التركيز على تدمي نسبه
المشاركه في الاقتراع ويشدد على ان الهدفه
هو التشكيكه في شرعيه مجلس النواب
في لقانا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا معكم تحميل الحكومه
الفلسطينيه واطراف اخرى من بينها حركه
حماس تحميلها السلطات الاسرائيليه
المسؤوليه عن وفاه الاسير ناصر ابو حميد
جراء الاهمال الطبي وناقشت معكم ايضا
التنديد بسياسه المتبعه في سجون الاحتلال
ضد الاسرى الفلسطينيين
والاستطلاع يا رايكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التاليه الذي يقول
مغفور تعرض اسرائيل لضغط دولي لوقف سياسه
الاهمال الطبي في حق الازهر
14% قالوا ان تلك الفرص كبيره بينما قال
15% انها محدوده بما راى واحد وسبعون
بالمائه انه لا فرصه اطلاقا لها
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا في منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخوله صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه
[موسيقى]
يوميا نتطرقوا خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون معنا في الحصاد ايضا
100000 من عمال قطاع التمريض في بريطانيا
يخوضون اضرابا جديدا مطالبين برفع الاجور
وتحسين ظروف العمل
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده لا تتوقع اي تقدما في
مفاوضات الاتفاق النووي مع ايران هكذا
لاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي جون كيربي مضيفا ان ذلك
الاتفاق ليس محله اهتمام كبير من بلاده في
الوقت الظاهر مرحبا في حاله صحفيه باي
محادثات يجريها الحلفاء الاوروبيون مع
ايران لكنه قال ناحيه اخرى ان ايران
ستحاسب على دعمها لروسيا في قتل اوكرانيين
وفق تعبيره
من جانبه قام مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف انه اجر لقاءا مع
وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد
الرحيم في الاردن وسط التدهور العلاقه بين
ايران والاتحاد الاوروبي وذلك على هامشي
مؤتمر بغداد الذي انعقد في البحر الميت
وقال بورال في تغريده له على تويتر انه
اكد خلال اللقاء على ضروره وقف الدعم
العسكري لروسيا والقمع الداخلي في ايران
مشيرا الى انه اتفق مع عبد اللاهين على
ضروره اتقاء قنوات التواصل مفتوحه
واستعاده الاتفاق النووي على اساس
مفوضاتهم
اما وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد
الله ايام فقال ان طهران ستدعم احياء
الاتفاق النووي ما لم تمسى خطوطها الحمراء
وهي مستعده للخطوه النهائيه لابرام
الاتفاق النووي مضيفا خلال مشاركته في
مؤتمر بغداد المنعقد في الاردن انه يتعين
على بقيه اطراف الاتفاق النووي ان تكون
واقعيه
خطوطنا الحمراء
والنصوص
المقدمه مستعيدون لاتمام المحاضر
المحادثات والوصول للخطوه النهائيه
لابرام الاتفاق شريطه ان تكون الدول
الاخرى تتعامل مع الموضوع بواقعيه وكذلك
همم تعاون ايران مع الوكاله الذريه هناك
تشهد على الخلفيه الناصعه
لاجراءاتنا واننا لازمنا انه ناكد على
الشرق الاوسط الخالي من اسلحه الدمار
الشامل ويجب ان لا تمنح للكيان الصهيوني
ايضا
على صعيد الاخر قال وزير الدفاع
البريطانيه روسيا تعتزموا منح ايران
مكونات عسكريه متقدمه مقابل مئات الطائرات
المسيره واضاف ولس في بيان له امام
البرلمان حول الصراع الروسي الاوكراني ان
ايران تعد احد اكبر الداعمين العسكريين
لروسيا على حد تعبيره
ا
المتهوره للمنشات النوويه يجب ان نحاسبهم
اصبحت ايران احد اكبر الداعمين العسكريين
لروسيا وفي مقابله تزويدها باكثر من 300
طائره مسيره من طراز كاميكازي تعتزم روسيا
الان تزويد ايران بمكونات العسكريه
الامن في منطقه الشرق الاوسط والعالم لدي
يجب ان نفضحه تلك الصفقه الواقع لقد فعلت
ذلك الان
وان يستفزكم
معنى الان من ولايه الدكتور جاريسيمل
المنسق السابق لشؤون عدم الانتشار في
البيت الابيض ومدير مركز كروان لدراسات
الشرق الاوسط اهلا وسهلا بك كيف يمكن الان
وصف العلاقه
مع ايران في ظل تشعب الملفات المختلفه
حولها
الاساس الجهد
لاحياء الاتفاق النووي لعام 2015
[موسيقى]
بين ايران من ناحيه والقوه الغربيه من
ناحيه اخرى حول تحقيقات الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه النوويه
اذا ايران
تسروا على ان هذه التحقيقات ينبغي ان
تتوقف قبل العوده الى الاتفاق النووي
والولايات المتحده والقوه الاوروبيه لا
ترغب في ان
تجبر الوكاله الدوليه على ايقاف هذا
التحقيق
والى لحد الان ايران رفضت ان تقدم
المعلومات المطلوبه منها اذا لا يبدو ان
هناك اي طريق الى الامام
لتنفيذ اتفاق بعوده بالعوده الى الاتفاق
النووي وعندما يقول جون كيربي بان بلاده
ليست مستعجله بشان هذا الاتفاق ما الذي
يعني ذلك
اعتقد ان اداره
وصلت الى ان ايران غير راغبه في قبول
الاتفاق بشروط الولايات المتحده التي
يمكن ان تقبلها على اساسها
وتمت تفاوض حوله من قبل جميع الاطراف بما
في ذلك ايران ولكن في الدقيقه الاخيره
مش ناوي كمان ولم تقدمت ايران بهذه
الطلبات حول تحقيق الوكاله الدوليه لتقى
النوويه
اذا
الان ليس هناك
دبلوماسيه نشطه بهذا المجال وايران لا
تبدو معنيه بتغيير موقفها
من ناحيه لانه هناك مشاكل داخليه كبيره قد
تتغير في المستقبل
اذا تمكنت ايران من
التحكم معها او التعامل مع هذه الاوضاع
الداخليه
اهلا وسهلا بك سيد القيام اذا كانت تواشن
غير مستعجله الاتفاق نووي مع ايران وايران
تقول على الاطراف ان تكون واقعيه حسب
تعبير عبد الله هيام هل نحن في مازق حقيقي
يعني في حقيقه الامر ان المفاوضات النوويه
التي بدات فيها ايران منذ العام الماضي هي
توصلت الى نتيجه مقبوله عند كل جميع
الاطراف سواء كان عند الجانب الايراني او
الجانب الاوروبي وحتى الامريكيين ايضا لكن
المشكله انه في اللحظه الاخيره الولايات
المتحده يعني الاداره الامريكيه
حاولت وضع ما توصلت اليه المفاوضات
النوويه من نتائج وضعته على الرف وهو جائز
حاليا جاهز من اجل التوقيع الاحياء
الاتفاق النووي لكن هناك الانتخابات
النصفيه التي جرت في الولايات المتحده همم
دار الامريكيه رات بان تحصر ايران في
زاويه من اجل همم الضغط عليها
لمناقشه لملفات اخرى ملفات اخرى اقليميه
الايرانيون رفضوا ذلك بشكل واضح
الايرانيون رفضوا ذلك لانه قالوا يجب
علينا ان نط- ان ننفذ الاتفاق النووي ان
تعود للولايات المتحده للاتفاق النووي
لموقع عام 2015 بعد ذلك يمكن ان نبحث
قضايا اخرى اذا كان هناك بحث في اي ملف
اخر لكن المشكله الاولى او المهمه الاولى
لدى الجانب الايراني هو احياء الاتفاق
النووي وحسب ما اعلم من معلومات وما اعرف
من معلومات ان الاتفاق النووي والاتفاق
لحيه الاتفاق النووي هو جاهز وموضوع على
الطاوله لكن الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه
وانا اعلم منذ البدايه الاداره الامريكيه
الحاليه اداره متردده ضعيفه لا لم تستطع
ان تتخذ قرار بالعوده بشكل سريع الى
الاتفاق النووي كما وعد بذلك الرئيس
الامريكي جاوب بعيدا خلال الحمله
الانتخابيه ووصلنا الى ما وصلنا اليه الان
الان البيت الابيض يقول بانه غير معني
بالاتفاق النوويه او لا يريد انخرط في
الاتفاق النووي في الوقت الحاضر لكنه يفسح
المجال امام الاوروبيين ان يعتقد هذه نوع
من الامتيازيه السياسيه التي تريد
الولايات المتحده ان تنتج هذا الطريق
على ايران الان اضيف ملف اخر وهو ملف
ما قيل عن دعم ايراني كامل لروسيا في
حربها مع اوكرانيا اسمح لي سال ضيفنا
السيد سماور في حول هذه النقطه واعود اليه
للتعقيب عليها سيد سمر همم اتهام اتهام
ايران بالوقوف الكامل مع روسيا هل سيعقد
العلاقه مع واشنط بشكل اكبر من السابق
يا اسطى كده اعتقد ان الامر يعقد
هذا الوضع يعقد الامور لانه هناك عقبات
سياسيه في الولايات المتحده وفي اوروبا
لقبول احياء اتفاق 2015
الاتفاق الذي تم التفاوض عليه في شهر
اغسطس فان الاوروبيين والامريكيين سيكونون
راغبين في ايه ايه اعاده العمل بالانتفاخ
لكن سيكون هناك انتقاد سياسي في الولايات
المتحده وفي اوروبا
لان
[موسيقى]
بسبب بدعم ايران لروسيا وايضا بسبب
العنف همم ضد همم في الساحه المحليه لامام
المظاهرات هذه الملفات
هل ستجعل ايران في وضع اصعب من السابق
يعني انا اعتقد بانه هناك يعني بشيء تخاف
منه ايران بعد كل هذه العقوبات وهذه
الضغوط التي مارستها الولايات المتحده
والدول الغربيه الان هناك ذريعه بقدرعتين
كما عبر عنها السيد جوزيف في تغريدته بعد
اجتماعه في وزير الخارجيه الايراني امير
حسين امير عبد الله يعني وهي قضيه التعاون
مع روسيا وقضيه حقوق الانسان ان يعتقد بان
هذه رائع التعاون الايراني الروسي في
المجال العسكري تحديدا هو ليس وليد اليوم
يعني نحن نتحدث عن طلب ايراني بشراء
صواريخ اس 300 منذ اكثر من خمس سنوات
وبالتالي هناك تعاون في هذا المجال
الايرانيون بعد ذلك طوروا هذه المنظومه
التي ارادوها من روسيا وصنعوا باور ثلاثه
همم ثلاثه سبعه ثلاثه وبالتالي هناك تعاون
بين الجانبين الان عندما تثار مثل هذه
القضيه قضيه التعامل العسكري بين طهران
وموسكو ان يعتقد بانها تدخل في اطار
الضغوط القصعه التي تمارسها الولايات
المتحده على ايران من اجل الضغط على ايران
للتنازل والقبول بالاتفاق على المقاسات
الغربيه هذه النقطه في غايه الاهميه
وعندما اقول بالمقاسات الغربيه هذه لا
تعني ان احياء الاتفاق المواقع في عام
2015 هناك شيء اخر الى جانب همم اتفاق
النووي جانب المنظومه الامنيه الاقليميه
وعندما نقول المنظومه الامنيه الاقليميه
معنى ذلك من الاسرائيلي بشكل واضح بدون
زياده او نقصان الايرانيون لا يريدون ان
يبحث ان يبحثون مع الجانب الامريكي او مع
اي جانب اخر امن اسرائيل هذه نقطه في غايه
الاهميه الايرانيون الايه كما قال جوبالتن
مستشار الامن القومي الامري السابقه قال
باننا ان همم نصدر همم السلاح الى
المجموعات الانفصاليه الايرانيه في اقليم
كردستان ونهرب هذه السلك هذه السلاح من
اجل تسليح الاحتجاجات ان يعتقد بان هذه
كلها ضغوط على الايرانيين للقبول بما
تريده الولايات المتحده بشان الاقليمي
شكرا لك محمد صالح صديقان من طهران شكرا
لك دكتور جري من مساجد
الان ينضم الينا من واشنطن الدكتور علي
واعد مدير مشروع ايران في مجموعه الازمات
الدوليه
واضح تماما بان الملفات تزداد تعقيدا بين
واشنطن والغرب وايران ايها اهم الان في
هذه المرحله
دكتور
انه لا احد يمكنه ان يتجاهل ان التقدم
الايراني في الملف النووي
مهم ولا يمكن ان يقرانا البعد النووي لان
ايران لا تبدو مهتمه
للوصول الى اتفاق حول الاتفاق النووي ومنذ
سبتمبر راينا اضرابات ومظاهرات في ايران
وايران
تتعاونوا عسكريا مع روسيا وانتقل الاهتمام
الى هاتين المسالتين
الاوروبيون والامريكيون
يدينون همم الانتهاكات حقوق الانسان
وهي عناصر لا يمكن تجاهلها
حتى لو كانت المفاوضات النوويه تسير بشكل
جيد اذا ليس هناك دبلوماسيه جديه في
المجال النووي لذلك يضاعفون من
الضغوط لعزل ايران ومن المهم ان لا احد من
الاطراف
من هذه القضايا اكثر واهميه من الناحيه
النوويه ولكن بين الوضع الداخلي في ايران
والعقوبات والملف النووي
والوقوف مع روسيا كما تتهم ايران ما الملف
الذي هو الاول ويمكن ان يؤثر في البقيه
استثمر في مصر
حول
الاستخبارات
الغربيه
الاضطرابات الداخليه لا تشكل خطرا على
امنها ويمكن ان نتخيل انه يحاولون
التاكيد على الوضع الداخلي في ايران ولكن
بما انه يبدو ان نقطه تحول بالنسبه لنظام
لم يتم الوصول اليها ولذلك ان التركيز على
التخفيض او الحد من الدعم العسكري
الايراني لروسيا هو المساله الاكثر اهميه
وهناك ايضا حدود لما يمكن ان يصل اليه
الغرب في دعم الشعب الايراني
دوله
ان تبني تغيير نظام الحكم قد فرضوا عقوبات
وعبروا عن التضامن لكن هناك حدودا لي مدى
التاثير الغربي على هذا الوضع الداخلي
عندما يقول جوزيف بريل بانه اتفق مع عبد
اللهيان على ابقاء قنوات التواصل مفتوحه
هل هذا مؤشر قد يكون واعدا
هو افضل من بديل لا يكون هناك قنوات تواصل
بين الطرفين وسيكون هناك المزيد من
التصعيد ربما حتى يكون هناك مواجهه عسكريه
الخوف في الغرب هو انهم يتخيلوا ان كان
اذا كنت جالسا في طهران فانك تعتقد انما
مهما كان ما تفعله فان الغرب سيعاقبك لذلك
ان همم
يقال لايران ان هناك طريقا للخروج اذا تم
تغيير السياسه
فذلك شيء ايجابي لكن بتبيعه الحال نحن
بعيدونا عن اي نوع من التفاهم الملموسه
حول تخفيف تصعيد في هذه الجبهات المختلفه
واا
ينبغي على ايران ان تتوقف وايضا روسيا
وهمم والح او ايقاف من تقديم الاسلحه
ومن الناحيه النوويه
الاختبار هو التعاون مع الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه النوويه
ولم يحدث اي شيء من ذلك كله لكن ترك الباب
مفتوحه افضل من المؤكد انه افضل من اغلاقه
شكرا
[موسيقى]
بسرعه تتجه حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا باكمال
شهرها العاشر وقد قال الرئيس الروسي الذي
مير بوتين ان بلاده تتعرض مره اخرى للتحدي
واقر بالمناسبه بصعوبه الوضع في مناطق
لوجانس ودنياتك وخيزون وزباروجيا في
المقابل اعتبر الرئيس الاوكراني ان
المعارك في بكمات التي زارها على خط
الجبهه في شرق بلاده باتت تكسر الجيش
الروسي ومن سماهم المرتزقه ياتي ذلك في
وقت الاعلى نتفه موسكو عن قصف الاوكراني
لمناطق داخل اراضيها
لا تجري الرياح التطورات الميدانيه بما
تشتهيه الشريعه موسكو خصوصا على شبهات
دنيا
بوتين يقر بصعوبه الوضع في هذه المناطق
اضافه
لوجيا
عن سيادته اليوم تواجه روسيا التحدي نفسه
مره اخرى وعلى خط المواجهه في العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه يظهر الجنود والضباته
والمتطوعون امثله استثنائيه
منذ شهور فالمعارك في بخموت وفقزنسكي بات
التكسير الجيش الروسي ومن وصفهم بالمرتزقه
الذين جندتهم روسيا وتقع بخموت على اطراف
دولي يصل لها بمدن مثل كريمه
الشمس
المكان الاكثر سخونه على خط المواجهه
باكمله والمعارك تجري على خط بطوله 2300
كيلو متر منذ ما يويار والاحتلال ويحاول
دخول الوقت يمر وقواتنا هي التي تلحق
الخسائر بالجيش الروسي لقد فقدت روسيا نحو
99 الف من جنودها في اوكرانيا وقريبا
لا يمكنها تجاوز حقائق على الارض يميزها
قصف اوكراني مناطق داخل الارض الروسيه
مؤشرنا على قدره كيف على نقل المعارك خارج
حدودها ولو رمزيا فقد اعلى حاكم مقاطعه
بريانسك الروسيه التي تقع على بعد تحوي
380 كلم جنوب غربيه موسكو قصف القوه
الاوكرانيه لبلده سوزوكي الحدوديه ما تسبب
في انقطاع الجزئيا للتيار الكهربائي كما
ساهم حاكم مقاطعه بالقرود الروسيه الجيش
الاوكراني بقص في مدينه شبيكينو المتاخمه
للحدود الروسيه مع اوكرانيا متى سبب في
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي عن ثلث سكان
المدينه بالمقابل اكد الجيش الاوكراني
استمرار القصف الروسيه على مقاطع
الجيش الاوكراني مواقع داخل التراب الروسي
في موسكو حكام الاقاليم الاوكرانيه
الاربعه التي ضمتها روسيا مؤخرا الى
اراضيها لبحث ما سمته موسكو العسكريه
وملفات تكامل ضمن الاتحاد الفيدرالي
الروسي كلها مؤشرات جوله جديده في الحرب
المستمره تشي بتغير في موازينها ولكن ايضا
في رهاناتها وربما اطرافها فالرئيس
البيلاروسيا اليكساندر لوكشينكو قال انه
لا يمكن لبلاده ضمانه امنها دون مساعده
روسيا مؤكدا نشر منظومه الصواريخ اس 400
واسكندر روسيه الصنع على الاراضي
البيلاروسيا قد يكون كل ذلك رسائل في غمره
اعلانات غربيه عن دعم عسكري مستمر لكيف
لكني يبدو عامل فصل الشتاء ايضا وراء
حسابات كل الاطراف ضمن معادله التقدم
والسيطره
معنى من موسكو مدريد الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه اهلا وسهلا بك عندما يعترف
الرئيس بوتن بصعوبه المرحله ماذا يعني ذلك
بوتين يعترف بصعوبه الوضع لانه بحسب
الاعلام الرسمي فان السيد بوتين قد اظهر
دائما ليس تفاؤلا ولكن رايا قويا حول
العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا لكن من
الواضح ان هناك عمليه كبيره وصعبه تدور
الان السلطات الروسيه والحكومه الروسيه
تعترف بان روسيا عليها ان توفر مبارده
كثيره من اجل الاستمرار في هذه الحمله
العسكريه ولكنه مع ذلك السيد اعترف
بصعوبه المرحله اذا اكرر السؤال صعوبه
المرحله بغض النظر عن ما يمكن ان يقوله
بعد ذلك هل من تفسير ذلك
اعدام
اعتقد انه في الغرب
فان الوضع ليس سهلا هذا واضح
لكن من الناحيه الاخرى يا سيد بوتين
يكرروا دائما ان الوضع تحت
السيطره وانه يسير حسب ما خفت له
ينضم الينا الان من كيف بوليسكي
مساعد وزير الدفاع الاخراني السابق عندما
يقول الرئيس بوتن ان الوضع صعب كيف يفهم
ذلك اوكرانيا
دقيقه
في المعركه
في ما يسميها بالاراضي المحتله
يبدا يبدو ان هناك
الان واعود مره اخرى للسيد عندما تصل
القذائف اوكرانيه ويصبح القصف داخل
الاراضي الروسيه هل هذا
تطور خطير بالنسبه للمرحله المقبله
لا اعتقد ذلك لان
بالنسبه
الاوكراني قد كرر ذلك عده مرات لكن ذلك لم
يغير الوضع الاستراتيجي
وروسيا مستمره
في حملتها الجويه والصاروخيه
وبالمسيرات ولا اعتقد ان مثل هذه الهجمات
الارهابيه ضد الاراضي الروسيه قد تغير
الوضع علاء في الميدان نعود مره اخرى
نفس السؤال للاسف وهو عندما يقول الرئيس
بوتن ان المرحله الحاليه صعبه كيف فهم ذلك
في الجانب الاوكراني
اوفس ستيشن
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لروسيا
في المعركه
والهجمات على الاراضي الروسيه هي
محاولات
تؤثر في السكان الروسي وهذه العمليه التي
تسمى العمليه العسكريه تصبح حربا شامله
لذلك ليس هناك مكان امن في روسيا
واوكرانيا
تهاجمه لا تهاجمه اهداف المدنيه ولكن
اهداف العسكريه
ازياء زياره الرئيس اوزيلنسكي الى الى
بكمات ما دلالتها
انها ليست الزياره الاولى للرئيس الى
الجبهه ولكن ذلك هو السبب الذي
يرفع معنويات الجنود
رئيس عندما رئيس البلد والقائد العام
للقوات المسلحه يفعل ذلك
فان ذلك فيه اشاده بالشجاعه التي يظهرها
ولا يمكن للرئيس بوتين او قادته ان يفعل
ذلك
وهو يتحدث الى الجنود ويستمع اليهم
ويبني زعامته وقيادته للبلد
استهداف الاوكرانيين للاراضي الروسيه الا
يجعل اوكرانيا في موقف صعب دوليا للدفاع
عن عن موقفها هذا
عظام انه
سيكونوا اي
موقف معارض من الغرب
لانكرانيه تستهدف مواقع عسكريه فقط
وهذا مختلف تماما عن الضربات او الاستهداف
الروسي الذي يضربوا المدنيين والمنشات
المدنيه شكرا
جزيلاند مساعد
ولاحقا في فتره المتابعه نتوقف عند
استهداف القوات الاوكرانيه مواقع في جنوب
غربي روسيا ونسال ضيفنا عن الدلالات
العسكريه لمثل هذه الخطوه
[موسيقى]
في مرحله جديده من الازمه في تونس اعلنت
حركه النهضه اذاعه نائب رئيسها ورئيس
الحكومه الاسبق علي العريض ايداعيه السجن
فيما تعرف بقضيه التسفير الى بؤر التوتر
وكاله الحركه ان القرار هو محاوله يائسه
ومفضوحه ممن وصفتها بسلطه الانقلاب
ورئيسها قيس سعيد للتغطيه على الفشل
الذريع في الانتخابات التشريعيه واكدت
الحركه ان الزوج بقت الحركه في السجن في
قضيه التسفير وغيرها يراد منه الضغط على
السياسيين الرافدين بما وصفته بالانقلاب
في تونس
انتهى زمن الحسابات الضيقه وحان وقت انقاذ
البلاد هكذا قال الامين العام لاتحاد
الشغل في تونس نور الدين الطبوبي في معرض
تشخيصه للاوضاع السياسيه والاجتماعيه في
البلاد وهو ما يتطلب حسب تعبيره الذهاب
الى حوار الوطني شامل خصوصا ان نتائج
الانتخابات التشريعيه تضمنت رساله واضحه
من التونسيين مفادها رفض المسار السياسي
الحاليه حقيقي
في سياق سياسيا اخر لم تفصل جبهه الخلاص
الوطنيه المعارضه تداعيه نتائج الانتخابات
التشريعيه عن قرار اعتقال نائب رئيس حركه
النهضه علي العريض في اطار التحقيق معه
حول قضيه التسفير فتزامنه مع الجدل بشان
نتائج الاقتراع ونسبه الاقبال الضعيفه هو
بحسب الجبهه محاوله من السلطه للتغطيه على
فشل الانتخابات كما حذرت من موجه اعتقالات
اخرى قد تطول قياديين في صفوف المعارضه
على هذه الهزيمه
فاختلق قضيه علي العريض وقع ايقافه لامام
الناس بان هناك التتبع للمسؤولين على بين
ظفرين الارهاب والفساد الاخرين
وحتى الداعمه للرئيس على ان نسبه العزوف
التاريخيه عن المشاركه في الانتخابات
الاخيره تت بمراجعه عديده ليس اقلها
الدعوه الى انتخابات الرئاسيه المبكره لا
يبدو ان ذلك غير شيئا من قناعات الرئيس
ومواقفه ففي اول رد فعل له اعتبر قيس سعيد
ان التشكيك في نتائج الانتخابات مردود على
اصحابه وان من ينتقدون ضعف الاقبال على
التصويت اليوم سبق انفاس في انتخابات
سابقه ببعض العشرات من الاصوات على حد
قوله تبين في القراءات والتاويلات يشير من
وجهه نظر المراقبين الى ان المشهد السياسي
في تونس يزداد تصدعا يوما بعد اخر في نظر
المعارضه انتهت مشروعيه الرئيس قيس سعيد
بعد نتائج الانتخابات التشريعيه وفي نظر
الرئيس لا يمكن تقييم النتائج الا بعد
الدور الثاني للاقتراع حاله الانقسام هذه
وارتداداتها على شتى المجالات لا يمكن
تجاوزها ليس بالاطراف الاجتماعيه الا
بالجلوسي الى طاوله الحوار ميساء الفطناصي
الجزيره تونس
ان الامم المتحده ملتزمه بتقديم الدعم
للشعب التونسي الذي يواجه تحديات كبيره
وتعدوا جريكا سلطات التونسيه الى ضمان
احترام حقوق رئيس الحكومه التونسيه السابق
علي العريض المعتقلي من قبل السلطات بما
في ذلك ما يتعلق بالاجراءات القانونيه
يتعين على السلطات التونسيه ضمان احترام
حقوق رئيس الحكومه التونسيه السابق علي
العريض بما في ذلك الاجراءات القانونيه لا
يمكننا التعليق على استعداد الناس
للمشاركه او عدم المشاركه في الانتخابات
في مواجهه تحديات كبيره لاسيما التحديات
الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه
انضم الينا الان من تونس سمير ديلو عضو
اللجنه التنفيذيه لجبهه الخلاص الوطني ومن
تونس العاصمه ايضا محمد بن جربه عضو تحالف
احرار اهلا بضيفين نبدا بالسيد سمير ديلو
اعتقال للسيد علي العريض ما الذي يضيفه من
تعقيد للمشهد التونسي
قانونيه
واستهدف الصحفيون واعفي القضاه واستهدف
رؤساء الاحزاب السياسيه
بالامس لمده ثلاثه عشر ساعه كلها كانت
دردشه تمثيليه من دفعنا الدفاع الى طرح
على قاضي التحقيق لماذا يجري هذا الحوار
في مكتب حاكم تحقيق في كتب مكافحه الارهاب
لماذا لا يجري في السندار ذكر وطنيه او في
حوار صحفي لان كله تعلم بالنقاش حول ظاهره
السلفيه حول ظاهره التسير حول ظاهره
الارهاب ولم يتعلق باعمال مجرمه تتبع
القضاء
في هذه الحاله سيد محمد امين الجربي
هل تعتقد بان الرئيس قيس سعيد
ال ال الانجراف لهذا النوع من المحاكمات
انما يزيدوا الموضوع تعقيدا حتى بالنسبه
اليه على الصعيد الشخصي
السلام عليكم
وعليكم السلام
القضائي وهذا حتى ما ذكره بعض المناصير
حركه النهضه والذين كانوا يترجحون بالامس
بخروج عوده من قيادات الصف الاول هو الذي
لا تريكو للبحث في حاله صراحه في بعض
الملفات الكبيره واولها ملف الت نحن
وانقلنا وان كان السيد سميرديله همم في
مداخله سابقه المعازيمي لاحمد الامام قال
انهم مطلع على الملف يعرف ان الملف فيه
اكثر من اكثر من 800 مما انه على ذمه قاضي
التحقيق انه يحدد
وكذلك
وكذلك قد التحقيق ليس من السجاده بان همم
لا يحل همم شخصيه هامه وعامه مثل الرئيس
الوزراء بقنا همم والقياده رقم اثنين في
حركه كبيره كحركه النهضه من دون اثباتن او
من دون دليل دمي غير او على الاقل هكذا
نتصور وبما انه على الاقل على الاقل قلت
بان القضاء مستقيم حتى اذا تركنا سيد امين
همم محمد امين الجربي موضوع السيد علي
العريض الان الصوره في تونس تبدو وكان
الرئيس في ضفه وكل القوه اساسيه
والمجتمعيه في ضفه اخرى واساسا اليوم همم
اتحاد الشغل عبر السيد نور الدين الطبوبي
كانه نفض يده بالكامل من الرئيس ويدعو الى
ضروره استخلاص العبر كيف سيتعامل الرئيس
مع هذا التطور
الاتحاد يحاول الاتحاد ما زالتي ما زال
همم ابظ على وثيقه مع الحكومه على زياده
بخمسه في المئه في القطاع العام والاتحاد
يحاول التملصا من همم من الوثيقه التي
امضى عليها متحججا بالوضع السياسيه نحن
نقول صحيح الاتحاد مشروعيه تاريخيه صحيح
الاتحاد واا من اكبر القوه الاجتماعيه في
البلاد ولكن على الاقل همم نطلب من
الاتحاد ان يتم ان يضيفي على منظوره لقبيا
وان يبتعد قليلا عن مربع
لنرى همم
ما يقوله في هذا التصريح للسيد الطبوبي
هو تصريحه منتظر وعلاقه ال الاتحاد برئيس
الجمهوريه بدات مسانده
لي عمليه 25 جويليه ولكن مع الايام تبين
على هذا المشروع لا يحمل من الاصلاح
التصحيح الا الاسم وانه مساء الحكم
انفرادي فبدا الاتحاد بلفظ يده تدريجيا
ولكن استسمحك يا استاذ محمد في
علاء ما قاله ضيفك الكريم ان السيد قيس
سعيد لا علاقه انه بيده تتبع القضائي بعض
عمليات ملاحقه المعارضين تمت تعليمات
المتلفزه مباشره من رئيس الجمهوريه بعضها
في مجلس الوزراء كما تعلق الامر من رئيس
الاسبق الدكتور المرزوقي او الامين العام
السابق للتيار الديمقراطه الاستاذ غازي
الشواشي وحتى عمليه اعتقال على العريض لما
حلها همم السيد رئيس الجمهوريه من خلال
قوله ان معارض
السابقين بفضيحه ان نسبه المشاركه في
الانتخابات همم
تلاحقهم همم تتبعت قضائيه
علاقه بالانقلاب السؤال الاخير سيد سمير
ديلو الحقيقه اليوم نشرت واشنطن بوست مقال
مهم جدا همم يقول بان على الرئيس بيد ان
يتصل هاتفيا بالرئيس قيس سعيد همم واصفا
الانتخابات الاخيره بانه مسرحيه هو يلوم
موقف الخارجيه الامريكيه ويقول على بيض ان
يطلب من الرئيس التونسي التنحي وان يهدده
بعقوبات كبيره
لاعاده الديمقراطيه كيف تنظرون الى همم
هذه المساله
انا طلعت انا هذا المقال هي لم تسمي
الرئيس التونسي بل سممته بن سمته
الديكتاتور الذي يحكم تونس وانا اعتبر ان
الراي العام الامريكي
والكثير من اعضاء الكونجرس هم مجلس النواب
الامريكي متحررون من واجب التحفظ الذي
يحكم الاداره الامريكيه الرسميه والذي
يلزمها باختيار بعض العبارات الدبلوماسيه
السيد قيس سعيد معزول داخل البلاد ومعذون
خارجها ولكنه مصر على حبس نفسه في حاله
انكار مطبق ومطلق شكرا لك من تونس شكرا
ايضا محمد من جربه من العاصمه التونسيه
ايضا
[موسيقى]
اكد المشاركون في مؤتمر بغداد 2 على
المضيء في التعاون مع العراق دعم لامنه
واستقراره وسيادته ومسيرته الديمقراطيه
وعمليته الدستوريه وجهوده لتكريس الحوار
سبيلا لحل الخلافات الاقليميه وذلك وفق ما
جاء في البيان الختامي للمؤتمر وقد جدد
المشركون دعمهم لبغداد في جهودها لترسيخ
دوله الدستور والقانون وبناء المؤسسات
القادره على مواصله التقدم واعاده الاعمار
واكد المشاركون ان نجاح مشاريع التعاون
الاقليمي يتطلبوا علاقات الاقليميه بنائه
قائمه على مبادئ حسن الجوار وعدم التدخل
في الشؤون الداخليه وعلى التعاون في تكريس
الامن والاستقرار ومحاربه الارهاب
هذا وقد طلب رئيس مجلس الوزراء العراقي
محمد شياع السوداني من من وصفها بالدول
الصديقه والشقيقه مساعده بلاده في استعاده
اموالها الموهوبه
الفساد المالي والاداري في صلب اولوياتنا
وقد بدانا عمليا حمله مكافحه الفساد
بدءا من اعلى المستويات
ونطلب من الدول الشقيقه والصديق
مساعدهنا في استرداد اموال العراق
المنهوبه والمهربه
وتسليم المطلوبين الذين يتخذون من هذه
الدول المحل اقامه لهم
وتعمل حكوماتنا بجد على تحسين البيئه
الاستثماريه في العراق من حيث التشريعات
والاجراءات والضمانات لتمكين المستثمرين
من دخول اسواقنا والافاده من الفرص
الكبيره فيها
هذا وقد قال نائب رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن الثاني انه التقى مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف برايل
في عمان وناقش معه العلاقات الثنائيه
والتطورات الاقليميه وتحقيقات الفساد في
البرلمان الاوروبي واضاف وزير الخارجيه
القطري انه جرت تركيزه على ضروره احترام
الاجراءات القضاء وعدم استباق نتائج
التحقيقات موضحا انه اكد لبوريل موقف قطر
الرافض للتسريبات الاعلاميه المضلله التي
تزج باسم بلاده في المساله
دهانات الخارجيه الامريكيه باشد العبارات
قرار حركه الطالبان منع الفتيات والنساء
من الجامعات ووصفته بغير المباره وقال
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه في مؤتمر
صحفي ان الولايات المتحده ستفرض اجراءات
لمحاسبه طالبان مع الاستمرار في مساعده
الشعب الافغاني من ناحيه اخرى رحبت
الخارجيه الامريكيه بقرار طالبان الافراج
عن مواطنين امريكيين قائله انها تدرك وان
ذلك يمثل بادره
حضر الرئيس التنفيذي لاتحاد هيئه الصحه
الوطنيه في بريطانيا ماثيو تايلور رئيس
الوزراء ريشي سوناك من ان سلامه المرضى
ستكون في خطر خلال اضراب تواقن السيارات
الاسعاف المقرره الاربعاء ويطالب المضربون
بتحسين ظروف عملهم وزياده اجورهم بشكل
يتناسب مع مستوى التضخم غير المسبوق في
البلاد منذ اربعه عقود
الاضراب الاكبر في يومه الثاني نقابه
طواقم التمريض البريطانيه مصره على
مطالبها اكثر من 100 الف من اعضائها
مطربنا في ثلاثه من اقاليم المملكه
المتحده الاربعه حتى تستجيب الحكومه
الناس كيف يتوقعون من ممرضه تعول عائله من
ثلاثه او اربعه اشخاص ان تعيش في هذا
الوضع الاقتصادي بنفس الراتب الذي كانت
تتقاده قبل عشره اعوام تقول رقابه التمريض
انه لابد من تعويض منتسبيها عن نحو عشر
سنوات من تجميد رواتبهم وتهدد باضرابات
اخرى في العام الجديد
الاعلام عليه ان يجلس معي في غرفه النوم
ونناقش الامر
الحكومه البريطانيه من جانبها ثابته على
موقفها بان على النقابه ان تقبل بما قالت
به هيئه مراجعه الاجور
المستقلهم ونساعد الجميع في البلاد هو
بالاستعداد والعمل على خفض تضخمه في اقرب
وقت
في يومه الاول اثر الاضراب بشده على
الخدمه الصحيه في البلاد حسب وزاره الصحه
اجلت الاف المواعيد للمرضى الا ان الامر
لم يكن بالسوء المتوقع لكن للمرضى راي اخر
ايه
يجب على الحكومه ان تحل المشكله مع تواقيم
التمريض في اقرب وقت
من اضرابات في قطاعات عده تشهدها بريطانيا
مؤخرا بسبب ارتفاع نسب التضخم وتجميد
الاجور للسنوات
بالتزامني مع موسم الاعياد في مسعا لزياده
الضغوط على الحكومه
تقول نقابه التمريض انها لا تدافع فقط عن
حقوقي منتسبيها بل تدافعوا ايضا عن حق
المواطنين في تلقي خدمه تمريضيه جيده
وتقول الحكومه انها تدافع عن المال العام
مال المواطنين وبينما يستمر الخلاف بين
الجانبين يبقى المواطنون هم المتضرره
الاكبر من تاثر الخدمه الصحيه اسد الله
الصاوي الجزيره لندن
[موسيقى]
نعود الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
اصبحت الاراضي الروسيه مره اخرى في مرمى
نيران الجيش الاوكراني فقد اعلنت مصادر
روسيه تعرض بلده سوزيكي المتاخمه للحدود
معه اوكرانيا لقصف من القوات الاوكرانيه
ادى الى اضرار في شبكه الكهرباء وخطوط
السكه الحديديه وتتبع الزوجيه مقاطعه
بنيانس الروسيه الواقعه قرب حدود روسيا مع
اوكرانيا وبيلاروسيا وعلى بعد نحو 400 كلم
تقريبا جنوب غربي
الاوكراني ايضا مدينه شبيكينو الحدوديه
وهذا ادى الى اصابه شخص وانقطاع الكهرباء
وتقول
في مقاطع
جنوب غربي روسيا وهي مركز صناعي وتعليم
مهم وقد تعرضت هي نفسها لهجوم صاروخيه
اوكراني قبل يومين
محاولات اوكرانيا نقل الحرب الى الداخل
الروسي بدات مبكرا لكن بشكل متقطع ففي
الاول من ابريل لسان الماضي قصفت مروحيتان
اوكرانيتان لتخزين الوقود في مقاطعه
الروسيه بحسب حاكم المقاطعه وفي الرابع
عشر من الشهر ذاته قالت روسي انها اجلت
سكان قريتين حدوديتين تابعتين
لمقاطعته بعد تعرضهما لقصفراني منتصف
اكتوبر الماضي بثت وسائل الاعلام الروسيه
مشاهده اندلاع حريق في محطه للكهرباء قالت
ان سببه قذف اوكراني بعد ذلك بيومين فقط
تعرضت ايضا بهجمات صاروخيه اوكرانيه
استهدفت مطرها الدولي ومستودعا للنفط
انضم الينا من بيروت الان العميد الياس
حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
وسهلا بك حضره العميد
هذا القصف
الاوكراني داخل الاراضي الروسيه ما خطورته
الحقيقيه
محمد هو لن يغير الصوره الاستراتيجيه
الكبرى او حتى موازين القوى ولكن له دور
معين ورسائل معينه على سبيل النساء انه
يمكن نقل الحرب من الاراضي الاوكرانيه الى
الاراضي الروسيه هذا هدف اثنين الوسيله
متوفره والدليل على ذلك هو قصف القاعدتين
منذ فتره والتي تبعد اكثر من 300 كلم عن
ال- ال- ال- الحدود الاوكرانيه
الاهم ايضا محمد انه نقل الحرب الى الداخل
الروسي يعطي الراي العام الروسي ان الحرب
ليست بعيد عنهم وقد تنتقل الى الداخل
والاهم ان السلاح المستعمل هو ليس سلاح
الغربي انما السلاح همم الاوكراني وهو من
صنع سوفيتي واخيرا وليس اخيرا محمد انه
ماذا سيفعل الرئيس بوتين بعد ان دمر كل
اوكرانيا يعني حدود التص والرد على هذا
الامر اصبح محدودا لدى همم الرئيس بوتين
اما سيذهب الى عمليات اغتيال قيادات
سياسيه كبيره او الزهاب الى ال- ال- البعد
النووي وهذا امر لكل منه محاذره الخاصه
الغرب كان يعارض في السابق استهداف
الاراضي الروسيه الان هناك نوع من الصمت
هل هذا ضوء اخضر
ااه صرح منذ فتره محمد احد مسؤول لم يعلن
عن اسمه من البنتاجون انه لم تعد تماني
همم امريكا من القصف الى داخل الاراضي همم
الروسيه حتى قيل عندما قصفت القائدتين
اننا لم نخطط لم نشجع ولم نمنع وهذا الامر
حق اساسي وحق رد ايه كما يقال بالانجليزيه
الريسي بروستي يعني المعامله بالمثل بمكان
ما حجم الدمار الذي يحصل في ثياب يبرر الى
حد ما هذا الامر ولكن اقول محمد مره اخرى
انه لن يغير هذه المعادلات ولكنه قد يغير
صوره المعركه منظار المعركه كيفيه تغطيه
المعركه وهو مهم جدا لرئيس جيلنسكي الذي
زار اليوم مخموت
شكرا جزيلا لك العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي متحدثا من بيروت
ومحللا استهداف اوكرانيا للعمق الروسي
بهذا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد شكرا على حسن
المتابعه وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]